how much of speed chess is recognizing
positions versus improvising tactics
mostly improvising tactics uh almost
every game goes off the rails at some
point rare is the occasion when you
follow some sort of main lineman you can
make positional moves in bullet but it
mostly reduces down to oh I see a cool
Square I'm just gonna telescope onto
that square that that's the extent of
strategic reasoning uh that you have in
bullet mostly it's spotting two or three
move tactics so so important to avoid
one move blunders because that really
kills your momentum and I do think it's
important to go into positions that you
generally understand that's why I was
doing King's Indian and I was playing
the Belgrade Gambit which which is an
opening I've analyzed and played a ton
on my stream and it it really brought me
a lot of comfort uh that we had
structures where I knew that I was
playing decent ideas but mostly it is
just flash pattern recognition and
almost all games no matter how they
begin ultimately boil down to who sees
more short tactics